Ben Affleck is making sure he's healthy
before dating again
a source tells ET Ben is focusing on
exercising and spending time with his
three children with ex-wife Jennifer
Garner you mentioned your kids now with
everything going on you and Jen always
still managed to co-parent how do you
guys make all of that work need or best
quote he's on the right path and doing
incredibly well with the full support of
Jen and his entire family Jen of course
helped to motivate Ben by being a
constant reminder that he must be the
best he can for his children Pam is good
Jen's good meanwhile the source tells us
Jen is continuing to date businessman
John Miller whom she's been linked to
since last October Ben sees how happy
Jen is with John Ben and Jen officially
divorced last October though they had
been separated since 2015 they remained
close even after the split and Jen has
been supportive of Ben throughout his
struggles it doesn't really bother me to
talk about alcoholism and being an
alcoholic it's a part of my life it's
something that I deal with it doesn't
have to sort of subsume my whole
identity and be everything but it is
something that you know you have to work
at and you know I feel like I had a
problem and I really want to address it
and I take some some pride in that and I
hope that you know and it is it's about
yourself your life your family our
source says then is in no hurry to date
again following his split from Saturday
Night Live producer Lindsay shook us for
the second time in April well Ben is
looking to date someone who is
supportive of his clean lifestyle it has
been a long road
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]